should men with date or marry earlier so
this is a good question and we were
talking about we were Yeah so basically
um I'll give you a quick backstory I was
raised by a single grandmother my mom
was homeless most of her life she passed
away a few years ago and I never met my
dad I've only recently recently met my
dad's out of the family so I I did not
have a father figure I had you know
friends parents who were good to me but
my grandmother luckily was a tough son
of a [__] so in a good way I love her
to death um but she was really really
like a tough woman
did you call her bubby grandma she hated
Bobby oh really she hated it but you've
ever heard of Yiddish this Hebrew and
Yiddish Yiddish is basically the uh uh
it's German with some Hebrew throne and
that's what like your views were living
during the Holocaust they created their
things yeah okay so Bubby is Yiddish for
grandmother so anyway my grandmother
just hated the word
um so long story short
because there was no money in my family
I grew up very poor uh I was always of
the
thought process of I need to have my
[__] together before I settle down
because I have no inheritance coming
nobody's paying for my wedding nobody's
paying for my nobody's covering any of
these bills if anything goes to [__]
nobody's gonna yeah maybe a friend but I
I can't rely on that I have no immediate
family that has the means to do any of
that so for my thought processes I want
to be settled on my own before I go and
meet my significant other well I maybe I
don't have to be rich but I want to go
and make sure that I have things going
because for me a vital thing is when I
meet my in-laws I want to be able to
shake my in-laws hands and say hey you
did a great job with your daughter I got
it from here whether she has a job or
not whether she can take care of herself
or not
I can provide for her and kids
thank you very much I got it from here
as opposed to coming in with no pot to
piss in
and then the father-in-law says great
now I have to take care of another
[__] kid meeting me I gotta pay for
the house I gotta pay for this I gotta
pay for that hey it's a turn off for the
woman and I just don't feel like I'm
doing my job so that's that's where I am
so that's why I'm I've been kind of so
to speak waiting I'm 28 I don't feel old
at all but I'm giving it that time
what's your take what do you guys think
well I'm curious to hear all of your
opinions
um I think women are a role of the dice
so I mean you could get a 22 year old
woman that seems perfect that leaves you
at 30 because she feels like she missed
out at her 20s
or you could get you know
um 30 year old girl that fans that is
very loyal to you I mean rare but it
happens
um I just look there's certain things
that have better probabilities and worse
probabilities but I just think at the
end of the day like women are a roll of
the dice
well yeah I mean we all are
it's really a crazy thing there's so
many rules to this whole marriage game
right you have these arranged marriages
they meet in the Jewish World you'll
have a guy and a girl who don't who've
never really met they meet one time they
get married like a week or two later
yeah stay married Indians Arabs just
like I guess ignorance is I'm I don't
believe ignorance is bliss because I
need to know I'm like I'm such a curious
person but you're opening the world most
of these people most of these people
like they don't have cell phones that
have you know internet browsers yeah
they don't know any better it's like if
there's a lot of a lot of so there's
something called they call them kosher
phones
like religious people have you know the
old school phones that literally only
have text messaging and phone calling
that's it I just I just think like even
like versus today aren't the verses
yesterday because they still like they
still most people people have social
media right so it's like a lot of girls
like they think that guys they think
they have the perfect woman and then you
know she turns 30 or 32 and thinks she
missed out on her 20s and leaves like
I've heard that story Millions too 100
so you're just you're just it's
that also become probably is because
he's not hitting it hard enough but uh
oh that's a big component he probably
didn't maintain frame
so let's go and say a short answer yes
men should wait you guys all think uh
men should wait yeah I mean I think men
need practice a lot of men a aren't
comfortable with themselves at younger
ages B you know they need to learn what
a woman likes and how to talk to women I
think it's a big thing especially as
friends and you know social media comes
out like how many people are just
talking like
a lot of the account back end is handled
by a dude so like these guys are talking
to a dude thinking they're talking to a
sexy girl but it's not so you know how
to play it because you're talking to
another dude yeah so exactly yeah it's
really like guys just don't know anymore
how to talk to girls I think is a huge
Factor that's going to play especially
as we go on in this direction but I mean
yeah I think I should wait and I think
that social media game is gonna be
for men in general well it's going to
make a certain personal percentage of
men very very lucky
in limited options and then for the most
men they're just going to be it's really
sad though like there's just so many men
that don't get any it's crazy well I
mean whoever's got the strong DM game
now I guess is winning that's about it I
don't have a big Instagram man but it's
just it's just through my it's really
through my life experiences because I've
always I never give a [__] about
rejection
and when I was younger when I was a
teenager I got rejected and I was
skinnier and but I would learn from it
and say okay why am I not getting the
results I want how do I figure out how
to go out to the clubs and go out to the
bars for men it's a numbers game forever
and then I just had my experiences I got
kicked in the ass through different job
went to the the military you build up
these accolades and this credibility and
you become more interesting and more
attractive and then you have to work
less at it because then you separate
yourself from a lot of the other guys
that have a boring job they had two
parents regular family nothing
interesting it's boring nobody cares I
agree yeah 100 okay
um now in terms of because there are
lots of lots of things to cover you
mentioned the double standard with uh
a lot of women being uh shunned for
promiscuity do you think that's a fair
double standard where like men are
respected because it's
because we touched it a little bit but
um yeah I mean it
for like
nobody's you don't go to unemployment
size she's like oh again I have to she's
like I explained this [__] I just think
you know you don't go to unemployment
the unemployment office and the world
doesn't say oh wow good job you got
unemployment and it's the same thing
with the double standard like No No
One's Gonna reward women for sleeping
around because that's easy it's hard for
men to get laid in general so the world
rewards what's hard to do
[Music]
I don't know why this is so hard for
people to understand I've like spoken to
most girls I've spoken to get it
but some of them
exactly yeah and it's like why do we why
do we say that if constantly go to
school if we don't know on some level
that it's true
like I said it'll it all comes back to
Nature like we try to round with it so
much and then at the end of it like we
all come back to that at the end of the
day it's so funny
okay so I just wanted to go into a
little bit more uh about umtr
what are some of what have been some of
your most interesting uh
um topics in terms of talking about the
videos that you've that you've spoken
about you know because you do those um
I don't know what of that I can pull out
that would be most interesting because I
feel like they were all interesting okay
do you mean like the types of things
what are things that are certain topics
that stand out to you because as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible